[Applause]  morant three seconds he drives banks  with five tenths of a second timeout  phoenix yes sir  [Applause]  get the man the basketball and give him  a driving lane he will make something  happen  [Applause]  john ranch giving the grizzlies the lead  a little bit of a hesitation there we're  talking about these situations  communication is key they don't talk out  the switch so bridges for half a second  thinks he's has to step to the next guy  that allows marant the step that he  needs to get to the basket but uh after  all of that this is not bad defense  because how about the degree of  difficulty to finish for morant hang in  the air to get it to go down this is a  tremendous  individual effort by moran  but will it be the game winner five  tenths of a second phoenix takes it